foreign
we have a huge frontal lobe and it's 40
of our entire brain
and most people uh when they have a
thought they just think that that's the
truth and I think one of my greatest
realizations in my own Journey was just
because you have a thought that doesn't
necessarily mean it's true
so if you think 60 to 70 000 thoughts in
one day and we do and ninety percent of
those thoughts are the same thoughts as
the day before and you believe that your
thoughts have something to do with your
destiny your life's not going to change
very much because the same thought leads
to the same Choice the same Choice leads
to the same behavior the same behavior
creates the same experience and the same
experience produces the same emotion and
so then
the act of becoming conscious of this
process to to begin to become more aware
of how you think how you act and how you
feel it's called metacognition and so
then why is that important because the
more conscious you become of those
unconscious states of Mind and Body the
less likely you're going to go
unconscious during the day and that
thought is not going to slip by your
awareness unchecked because you're it
means to know thyself the word
meditation means to become familiar with
so as you become familiar with the
thoughts the behaviors And the emotions
of the old self you're retiring that old
self as you fire and wire new thoughts
and condition the body into a new
emotional state if you do that enough
times it'll begin to become familiar to
you so it's so important
just like a garden if you're planting a
garden you got to get rid of the weeds
you got to take the plants from the past
year and you got to pull them out the
rocks that sift to the top that are like
our emotional blocks they have to be
removed the soil has to be tenderized
and broken down we have to we have to
make room to plant the New Garden so
primarily we learn the most about
ourselves and others when we're
uncomfortable because the moment you
move into that uncomfortable State
normally a program jumps in when that
program jumps in it's because the person
doesn't want to be in the present moment
and engage it consciously
so when you teach people how to do that
with a meditative process
turns out that when they're in their
life they're less likely to emotionally
react they're less likely to be so rigid
and believe the thoughts they were
thinking they're more aware of when they
go unconscious back into a habit and
that is what starts the process of
change and so we have to unlearn before
we relearn we have to break the habit of
the old self before we reinvent the new
South we have to prune synaptic
connections and Sprout new connections
we have to unfire and unwire and re-fire
and rewire we have to unmemorize
emotions that are stored in the body
then recondition the body to a new mind
into a new motion like deprogram and
reprogram that's the act and it's a
two-step process the fastest way to
change your habits is to change your
environment you ever notice how when
you're in a different environment maybe
you go on vacation maybe you go to an
event or seminar
you start doing different things you are
still you and you do some of the things
that you used to do but all of a sudden
you're doing new things that become a
part of your regular routine you've ever
been away for a couple weeks and
discover that you built up some new
habits and maybe some are healthy maybe
some are unhealthy but if you've ever
been away and you notice that you've
picked up some new habits why well
because the environment demanded it
because everybody else was doing it
because it was so easy natural
comfortable to do that that that's why
you do it too and so if you want to be
able to switch your habits quickly you
change your environments now you may not
always be able to go on vacation or go
to events or seminars or those those are
options but it starts with you figuring
out well what are
the habits that you want to develop who
are the people that you want to be
around and when you are around those
people you will start to think
differently which will lead to you
behaving differently when you see other
people doing it you're going to want to
do it more when it's in your environment
more you're going to want to do it more
too this morning I was talking to a
YouTuber big YouTuber bigger than me
more subscribers than me slightly
different Niche and I remember meeting
him in California
a couple years ago and one of the things
he was struggling with was staying
consistent and I'm very consistent and
one of the things I was struggling with
was staying healthy while I was on the
road and we're having dinner together
and he was eating
super clean he was eating fish and salad
and I probably had a burger or something
fries and
coming away from that what I realized
was
whoever is more confident wins and when
you're around other people whoever's
more confident in the habit that they
have will be the dominant habit that
both of you end up picking up so if we
were hanging out together more here's
what would happen I would become a lot
healthier in my eating and he would
become a lot more consistent in his
content because we'd be inspired by each
other because he'd see me working with
make my videos and he'd feel bad that he
was making his and he'd have to go and
start making his and I see him eating
healthy all the time and be like man I
should be eating healthy and they would
force me to do it as well that
environment switch would allow us to
create much better stronger habits so
now you got to be careful about the kind
of people who you're hanging out with
and if you look at the people you've got
right now around you chances are
they're keeping you stuck they're
keeping you small they're keeping you
where you are and you're probably
pouring into them right you're the one
giving them love giving them
encouragement giving them support
into them you're you're taking your cup
and pointing to them and it's great and
it's and you should keep doing that and
it's amazing and it's it's fulfilling
but who's pointing to you and who's
making you get to the next step because
if you don't have that you're gonna
you're gonna continue to stay small or
just have slow growth compared to where
you could be so how do we get some
practical steps okay that's great what
do we actually do how do you start
making that change happen well the first
step is to figure out what is it that
you want to get better at you know what
area of your life or business do you
want to be better at is it you want to
stay more consistent on your habits you
want to you want to learn how to make
money you want to have a better
relationship you want to take care of
your health like what is the thing that
you actually want to get better on
getting Clarity on what that thing is
two is to then surround yourself as much
as possible with
with content not even people because it
could be great to say hey awesome hang
around Joe dispense all the time and you
will you will become better you will
meditate more you will solve your
awesome but you don't know Joe dispenser
and he's probably not taking on students
right now or mentees right or Elon Musk
or Oprah Winfrey or whoever right you
don't know them and so that's not a
practical answer but you can hang around
their content
that's why I make these videos every day
because if every day there was a new
video for you hopefully it lifts you to
bring some of the best experts in the
world the people that I find inspiring
and learn from to share their message
every morning you don't have that person
in your life but there's videos for you
so step two is step one we're figuring
out what is it that we want right where
do we want to improve and get better
step two is who are the people who are
who are living it who are preaching it
who are living it who actually inspire
you and there's so many different people
out there who are doing it and everybody
has their own way I like to say that you
know uh naira Thomas is going to yell at
you through it and Oprah Winfrey is
going to hug you through it but they
have very similar messages
whoever's style you connect with the
most have that more consistently in your
environment follow them on Instagram
subscribe to them on YouTube put their
quotes on the wall around you create
your own environment of the people who
make you feel like you want to do more
who inspire you to step out of your
comfort zone and take on those new
habits that you want to actually adopt
right so you're creating a new
environment for yourself without having
to go live with Joe dispenza or Elon
Musk or Oprah Winfrey
okay so I call them aspirational mentors
and and that can be fundamental and
that's where most people need to start
because you have access to their books
and their videos and their content you
have that access right now and that can
make a big shift in you if you start
surrounding yourself with it every day
and then step three is to is to get more
in-person connections and this is more
time consuming and more challenging and
harder to find the right fits but
can make a big shift as well in your
life so I don't want to only rely on and
it's why step two was actually having
just content that you're learning from
but step three if there's people that
you're learning from do they have an
event do they have something coming up
can you hang around people who are
like-minded who are also taking on
challenges I'm doing a challenge right
now inside my movement makers program
where Movie Makers is For Thought
leaders who are trying to get to the
next level with their content and break
through and have a greater message and
reach more people
but a lot of people haven't been as
consistent as they should have because
they're the only ones doing this who
don't know anybody else making content
their family thinks they're crazy like
why are you making another video they're
not seeing results that they don't have
a peer group they don't have anybody to
connect with and talk to and
this can relate to any goal that you
have movement makers is just for kind of
thought leaders making content but
whatever goal that you have if you're
the only one that you know who's doing
it it's really hard to stay consistent
on it so our movement makers challenge
is every month we have a challenge where
you have to make a lead magnet for your
business a solo video and then three
collaboration videos with other people
in the group so it forces you to start
making content and for a lot of the
members this is the most consistent
they've ever been now in making content
because one they're doing it together
you feel like you're doing it with other
people even though a lot of the content
that you make
outside will still be separate from the
members you're not doing a business
together but it feels like they're
connected we're taking on this challenge
together and then in the collaboration
videos you're you're connecting with
people you're doing interviews with
people you're you're sharing your
thoughts and feedback it's not just you
talking to a camera in the car with your
dogs by yourself anymore
and that really really really really
matters it really matters so getting
some kind of support group connecting
with other people who are on the same
Journey going to seminars or events of
of humans that you can talk to and
connect with who are doing the thing
that you want to do because the more
that you're around those people the more
you're going to stay consistent on the
habits that you want to build so using
that three-step process can absolutely
change your life
it's it's entirely possible and if
you're watching videos like this you're
you're already on the growth mindset
Journey right you're already into
personal development you already know
you want to do more and serve more and
help more and this helps you elevate
yourself to the next level because you
are probably the most
ambitious person that you know that
you're hanging out with and and that's a
great place to be because you're serving
and helping but it also sucks because it
limits your growth of what you could
become where if you can one clearly
identify what you want to change what is
the Habit that you want to take on where
are you not satisfied anymore in your
life not beating yourself up and saying
you suck but like the next level of
growth that you want to accomplish
yourself and then two following people
just through content who are living that
message who are who are not just
speaking it but live in it who who when
you watch their their videos you
actually get inspired to go make a
change in your life who are those people
subscribe to them follow them every day
watch their content read their books put
their stuff up on your wall as a
reminder you're creating a new
environment for yourself and then three
is actually connecting with humans
joining a group like Movie Makers or
something else going to events where
your your tribe is at so that you are
not alone doing this journey feeling
isolated and like you don't belong make
those three changes it will change your
life the difference between where you
are now where you could be is just the
consistent habits that you're putting in
you know this I know you know this now
it's about taking the actual action to
stay consistent on those habits
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all of the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there
Newtonian world is all about the
predictable it's all about predicting a
future but the quantum model of reality
is is about causing an effect the moment
you start feeling abundant and worthy
you are generating wealth the moment
you're empowered and feel it you're
beginning to step towards your success
the moment you start feeling whole your
Healing Begins and when you love
yourself and you love all of life you'll
create an equal now you're causing an
effect and I think that's the the
difference between living as a victim in
your world saying I am this way because
of this person or that thing or this
experience they made me think and feel
this way when you switch that around you
become a creator of your world and you
start saying my thinking and my feeling
is changing an outcome in my life and
now that's a whole different game and we
start believing more that we're creators
of reality so how do we then go from
that like mechanistically
to begin this visualization process of
something that's empowering it's me in a
different state It's My Future Self is
it meditation is it what does that look
like if you're not being defined by a
vision of the future
then you're left with the old memories
of the past and you will be predictable
in your life
and if you wake up in the morning and
you're not being defined by a vision in
the future as you see the same people
and you go to the same places and you do
the exact same thing at the exact same
time
it's no longer that your personality is
creating your personal reality now your
personal reality is affecting or
creating your personality your
environment is really controlling how
you think and feel unconsciously because
every person everything every place
every experience has a neurological
Network in your brain every experience
that you have with every person produces
an emotion so some people will use their
boss to reaffirm their addiction to
judgment they'll use their enemy to
reaffirm their addiction to hatred
they'll use their friends to reaffirm
their addiction to suffering so now they
need the outer world to feel something
so
to change then is to be greater than
your environment to be greater than the
conditions in your world and the
environment is that seductive so then
why is meditation the tool well
let's sit down let's Close Our Eyes
let's disconnect from your outer
environment so if you're seeing less
things there's less stimulation going to
your brain if you're playing soft music
or you have earplugs in less sensory
information coming to your brain so
you're disconnecting from your
environment if you can sit your body
down
and tell it to stay like an animal stay
right here I'm going to feed you when
we're done you can get up and check your
emails you can do all your texts but
right now you're going to sit there and
obey me
so then when you do that properly and
you're not eating anything or smelling
anything or tasting anything you're not
up experiencing and feeling anything you
would have to agree with me that you're
being defined by a thought right so when
the body wants to go back to its
emotional past
and you become aware that your attention
is on that emotion and where you place
your attention is where you place your
energy you're siphoning your energy out
of the present moment into the past and
you become aware of that
and you settle your body back down in
the present moment because it's saying
well it's eight o'clock you normally get
upset because you're in traffic around
this time and here you are sitting and
we're used to feeling anger and you're
off schedule oh it's 11 o'clock and
usually check your emails and judge
everybody well the body's looking for
that that predictable chemical state
every time you become aware that you're
doing that and your body is craving
those emotions and you settle it back
down into the present moment you're
telling the body
it's no longer the mind that you're the
mind and now your will is getting
greater than the program and if you keep
doing this over and over again over and
over again over and over again just like
training a stallion or a dog it's just
gonna say I'm gonna sit and the moment
that happens when the body's no longer
the mind when it finally surrenders
there's a liberation of energy
we go from particle to wave from matter
to energy and we free ourselves from the
chains of those emotions that keep us in
the in the familiar past and we've seen
this thousands of times in fact we can
actually predict it now on a brain scan
we have a thousand reasons I have more
than a thousand Reasons every day to be
unhappy with managing companies and
staff and people all that but but then
when you rise above that and you choose
just who you want to be
uh I think it makes a big impression uh
on your on your family first yourself
your family and your friends and the
people you work with and then finally
our communities so I think that people
are starting to figure that out there
and and when they imagine oxytocin
levels in our student body
the love hormone the love chemical 200
times outside of normal the latest
research on oxytocin is slight slight
elevation on oxytocin it's impossible to
hold a grudge now so then what that
means is you feel
so amazing that why would you want to
hold a grudge against that person so
forgiveness then is not something that
you have to try to do to be spiritual
it's the side effect of saying I don't
want to give up this feeling for you or
anybody so I'm letting it go I'm free in
you I'm freeing myself and my goodness
there's more liberation of energy I call
that the natural state of being and
we're knocking on that door why
because as you begin to open your heart
to life again and you start trusting in
your future and trusting in yourself a
little bit more and you start
self-regulating with your heart you do
that properly and you lead from that
place from that level of awareness your
life will change in dramatic ways and
why is that essential because when
people start doing that effectively
oxytocin signals nitric oxide nitric
oxide signals a chemical called
endothelial derived relaxing factor and
that causes the arteries in your heart
and lungs Jay to literally swell just
like when you're when your sexual organs
are aroused and blood flow moves into
them male and female that's a different
Consciousness there's a different energy
in there imagine the same intensity
moving into your heart that's what
people are experiencing that is a level
of love
it's not like a love for your puppy it's
not like the love for your partner this
is transcendent of that this is the most
familiar unfamiliar feeling you will
ever have it'll be distant and at the
same time very close and you'll start to
see the hidden meaning behind all things
and now when you walk in the presence of
your greatest betrayer
the person who threw you under the bus
whatever it is when you walk in from
this place there will be no emotional
reaction you will just see that person
for who they are who you used to be no
compassion then is no longer something
that you have to try to do it's the end
product of doing the work and I think
that Mystics and Saints and masters of
old understood this
so when they thought of that person they
didn't allow that thought to produce a
feeling or an energy that would lower
their energy they understood that when
they had the thought of that person they
saw their limitation it wasn't hurting
them it was only hurting themselves now
I think that the world was doing that
wow we'd have a very different world as
I said 70 of the time people live in
stress and living in stress is living in
survival now
all organisms in nature can tolerate
short-term stress you know a deer gets
chased by a pack of coyotes when it
outruns the coyotes it goes back to
grazing and the event is over and the
definition of stress is when your brain
and body are knocked out of balance out
of homeostasis
the stress response is what the body
innately does to return itself back to
order so you're driving down the road
someone cuts you off you jam on the
brakes you may you give them the finger
and then you settle back down and the
event is over and boom now everything's
back back to normal
but what if it's not a predator that's
waiting for you outside the cave but
what if it's your co-worker
sitting right next to you and all day
long you're turning on those chemicals
because they're pushing all your
emotional buttons when you turn on the
stress response
and you can turn it off now you're
headed for a disease because no organism
in nature can live in emergency mode for
that extended period of time it's a
scientific fact that the hormones of
stress down regulate genes and create
disease long-term effects
human beings because of the size of the
neocortex we can turn on the stress
response just by thought alone we can
think about our problems and turn on
those chemicals
that means then our thoughts could make
us sick
so if it's possible that our thoughts
could make us sick is it possible then
our thoughts could make us well the
answer is absolutely yes so then what
are the emotions that are connected to
Survival Let's name them
anger aggression hostility hatred
competition fear anxiety worry pain
suffering guilt shame unworthiness Envy
jealousy those are all created by the
hormones of stress and and psychology
calls them normal human States Of
Consciousness I call those Altered
States of consciousness
so then we tend to remember those
traumatic events more because in
survival you better be ready if it
happens again that's and and the
survival Gene is switched on you could
have 10 really great things that happen
to you in your day
and you just have one bad thing that
happens and you cannot take your
attention off that bad that that unhappy
thing because the survival Gene is
switched on many years ago after the DNA
Helix was discovered by Watson Crick
they said the blueprints of life you
know all diseases are created from genes
turns out less than five percent more
like one percent of people on the planet
are born with a genetic condition like
type 1 diabetes or Tay Sachs disease or
sickle cell anemia the other 95 to 99
percent are created by lifestyle and by
choices you can take two identical twins
exact same genome one dies at 51 the
other one dies at 85. same gene
different environment so
all of a sudden they said we lied that
was wrong it's not genes that create
disease it's the environment that
signals the gene that creates disease
well okay but that's not the whole truth
too because you could have two people
working side by side in the same Factory
one gets cancer after being exposed to a
carcinogenic for 25 years both working
for 25 years the other one has no cancer
at all so there must be some internal
order
that would cause one person to not get
it while another one does so is it
possible then if the environment signals
the Gene and it does and the end product
of an experience in the environment is
called an emotion
can you signal the gene ahead of the
environment by embracing an elevated
emotion
we've done the research on this we
measured
7500 different Gene expressions in a
group of people
I came to an advanced event for four
days
and we had them doing a seated
meditation a walking meditation a laying
down meditation a standing meditation
and at the end of four days just four
days
the common eight genes that were up
regulated two genes to suppress cancer
cells and tumor growth two genes for
neurogenesis the growth of new neurons
in response to novel experiences and
learning the gene that signals stem
cells to go to damaged areas and repair
them the gene for oxidative stress was
upregulated we started seeing all these
genes that are very very healthy to
cause the body to flourish imagine if
people were doing that for three months
we also measured telomeres the little
shoestrings on the end of DNA that tell
us our biological age we ask people
to do the work meditation five out of
seven days for 60 days
measure their telomeres to determine
their biological age 60 days later
74 percent of the people lengthen their
telomeres forty percent significant
change 20 percent a very remarkable
change that means that they got a little
bit of their life back if they
lengthened by 10 they got 10 percent of
their life back 15 20 years ago
um everybody wanted to stay in the
philosophical realm nobody wanted to do
anything with it but this is this is a
time in history where it's not enough to
know this is a time in history to know
how because information is so available
right I mean you don't need a doctor you
don't need a priest you need a rabbi you
don't need a governor you don't need a
teacher to gain information you need an
authority any longer because of
Technology we have access to information
well information
creates awareness
and awareness is consciousness and you
can't have Consciousness without energy
so people are beginning to wake up with
a greater level of awareness of what's
possible so
15 years ago 20 years ago 10 years ago I
walked out and there was always a little
resistance
but now people are coming because they
want to actually experience the truth of
it so that makes my job easier because I
can just walk out and just fire away
because people are prepared they're
informed they're ready so anything
that's not consistent with that energy
or that level of awareness those
paradigms are beginning to break down
whether it's education whether it's
religion whether it's politics economics
the environment the medical model
everything's collapsing because people
are informed so
I love that idea because when people
show up and they say well listen uh I
understand that I have a health
condition I understand that it's taken
me 10 years of being unhappy 10 years of
living in stress 10 years of living in
fear that's actually begin to Signal or
select and instruct the gene that
creates the disease well it may take me
some time then to unlearn that process
to break that conditioning process so
there's a practical understanding now
but
something amazing has happened I mean
we've spent over 10 years doing very
Advanced scientific studies we've done
over 8 500 brain scans we've measured so
many thousands of Hearts because if
you're going to create a new future it
requires a clear intention and elevated
emotion well let's train our people how
to create really really high level brain
coherence and really really really
self-regulating heart coherence why
because if you're going to believe in
that future that you're creating with
all of your heart it better be opened
and activated and you better know how to
do that and you better understand the
science of what happens we've measured
Gene regulation 7 500 different Gene
regulations we know you can change your
gene expression in four days we've
measured it you're not you're not doomed
by your genes you're your own genetic
engineer that that you can lengthen your
life when we've seen telomeres actually
lengthens 60 days of meditation that you
you add days to your life you're
changing your genetic future that you
can strengthen your immune system by
thought alone that's
that's the evidence from the scientific
perspective and people love the evidence
because they start to see that's
possible
you're not going to find that in a
pharmaceutical commercial you're not
going to find that out there in the
world you got to really be hungry and
look for
so then that sets the stage for the
person to come and want to have that
experience there may not be so quick to
say hey I want to heal my body right
away they may say I need to get my brain
a heart coherent first and I gotta begin
to put my effort into learning how to do
this like learning any skill yeah I
think uh you know if we everything
starts with a thought I mean everything
that you do in your life you you have to
have a thought before you initiate an
action right so so if you believe that
your thoughts have something to do with
your destiny like any great leader in
history understands that
the first thing you have to do is you
have to decide are you going to be
defined by a vision of the future or are
you going to live by the memories of the
past so give you an example
most people wake up in the morning and
your brain is a record of the past it's
an artifact of everything you've learned
and experienced to this moment right
it's a it's a Memory Bank
so most people wake up in the morning
and they start thinking about their
problems and those problems are
connected to certain people and things
at certain times and places and the
moment they start start turning on those
circuits those memories are actually
causing them to think in the past every
single one of those memories has an
emotion associated with them and
emotions are the end product of past
experiences so then the moment they
recall the event or the they recall some
problem in their life they start feeling
unhappy they start feeling discouraged
they start feeling anxious now thoughts
of the language of the brain and
feelings of the language of the body and
how you think and how you feel creates
your state of being so we could say then
most people's entire state of being when
they start their day is in the familiar
past well if you live in the familiar
past then it makes sense you're going to
create the predictable future and so
what happens for most people is they get
stuck in their biology so think about
this your body is your unconscious mind
it doesn't know the difference between
an experience in your your life that
creates an emotion and an emotion that
you can create by thought alone so if
you're living by the same emotion every
single day and those emotions are
influencing your thoughts and you can't
think greater than how you feel or
feelings have become the means of
thinking you're thinking in the past
your lens of the future is going to be
colored by the past so you can't see
possibilities so most people like to
wait for crisis or disease or diagnosis
before they wake up yes enough to see
well the challenge is is that biology
tends to be redundant so
if you keep thinking the same thoughts
and those thoughts be begin to fire
certain circuits in your brain the nerve
cells that fire together wire together
so all of a sudden you start getting
hardwired and those are the thoughts
that you can think the easiest at the
same time those thoughts produce
chemicals called emotions and the next
thing you know your body gets accustomed
to living by the same emotions and it
could be guilt it could be unhappiness
it could be pain but at least it's
familiar to you at least you can predict
it so some people would rather cling to
The Familiar than take a chance in
possibility so for most people then they
say well
I don't really see how my thoughts have
anything to do with my destiny well
that's because
95 of those thoughts are subconscious
programs right so you're not even
conscious that you think those thoughts
so the first step to change is starting
to think about what you've been thinking
about and change it and and then when
you begin to observe those thoughts
you're no longer the program you're the
Consciousness observing just simply by
being an observer of your thoughts right
so so though so most people though when
they when you do that when you decide to
really take a look it's like letting a
match in a dark place so you feel
uncomfortable so it's easier to turn on
your TV it's easier to to play with your
cell phone to distract yourself from
those feelings well when you understand
that change really requires becoming
uncomfortable to a certain degree and
that's normal that you're leaving the
known and you're stepping into the
unknown then it begs the question what
thoughts do you want to fire and wire in
your brain because your attention on
those thoughts begins to reorganize
circuitry remold the brain I think that
we Define reality with our senses and I
think that is one of the biggest
Illusions so the fundamental question is
can you believe in a future
that you can't see or experience with
your senses yet but you've thought about
enough times in your mind that your
brain has literally changed to look like
the event has already occurred now the
latest research in plasticity says
that's absolutely possible and can you
select a new possibility in the quantum
field and begin to emotionally Embrace
that future every single day to such a
degree that your body as the unconscious
mind the objective mind does not know
the difference between the experience in
your life that's creating the emotion
and the emotion that you're fabricating
by thought alone to the degree that you
begin to Signal new genes in new ways to
change your body to look like the
experience has already happened now yes
the latest research in epigenetics says
it's absolutely possible now think about
this every day
installing the circuitry every day
conditioning the body into the emotion
of the future that your body begins to
change to look like it's already
happened now this is where it gets fun
because now you no longer have to go
anywhere to get it now it begins to come
to you you become the vortex for the
magnet to your destiny so then people
who come out of their meditation and
they say well I just focused on my
wealth why isn't it there well you're
not that good if you're asking why isn't
it there you're back to the old person
again
stay in that state for an extended
period of time as
an experiment as the scientist in your
life to keep your energy connected to
the to the dream of your future
and then see what kind of effects begin
to take place without moving into
impatience without moving into
frustration without starting to analyze
why it hasn't happened or when that is
the Trap of defining reality with your
senses so you have the thought of your
future and you don't see it then you
experience separation but people who are
practicing this work they have the
thought of their future and they feel
the emotion of their future they're
still connected to it right so that
takes practice and it's just learning
like hitting a golf ball hitting a
tennis ball dancing the salsa you know
crocheting whatever it is you gotta you
gotta start out staying real conscious
and learning then you get good at it and
gets to be instrumental gets to be fun
and that's that's what I want for
everybody that the Act of Creation
should be a blissful type of ecstatic
loose free process and um and so
I love the idea of people taking time
out of their lives
to prove to themselves that if they're
defined by the vision of the future then
they're not living by the memories of
the past and that's where the unknown
exists so many people the unknown is a
scary place so they don't see that
future because they're used to seeing
that future with evidence with their
senses and the you have to be able to
get beyond that and stay in the unknown
stay in that discomfort and then in that
moment to be begin to self-regulate like
oh I'm starting to feel a little anxiety
ooh I'm starting to feel a little
frustration that's the defining moment
where your body is going back to the
past because emotions are a record of
the past or you go into routine again so
you catch yourself
it's a victory and if you keep catching
yourself those victories add up and it's
not so much about your wealth or your
health or your freedom or your new
relationship
it's actually about who you become if
you're sitting down and you start
thinking about uh some future worst case
scenario that you're Conjuring up in
your mind and you begin to feel the
emotion of that event
your body doesn't know the difference
between the event that's taking place in
your world outer world and what you're
creating by emotion or thought alone so
most people then they're they're
constantly reaffirming their emotional
states so when it comes time to give up
that emotion they can say I really want
to do it but really the body is stronger
than the mind because it's been
conditioned that way so
the servant now has become the master
and the person all of a sudden once they
step into that unknown they'd rather
feel guilt in suffering because at least
they can predict it being the unknown is
a scary place for most people because
the unknown is uncertain and people say
to me well I can't predict my future
I'm in the unknown and I always say the
best way to predict your future is to
create it not from the known but from
the unknown what thoughts do you want to
fire and wire in your brain what
behaviors do you want to demonstrate in
one day the act of rehearsing the
mentally closing your eyes and
rehearsing the action
they're rehearsing the reaction of what
you want or yeah the action of what you
want by closing your eyes and mentally
rehearsing some action if you're truly
present the brain does not know the
difference between what you're Imaging
and what you're experiencing in 3D World
so then you begin to install the
neurological Hardware in your brain to
look like the event has already occurred
now your brain is no longer a record of
the past now it's a map to the Future
and if you keep doing it priming it that
way the hardware becomes a software
program and who knows you just may start
acting like a happy person the stronger
the emotion you feel from some event in
your life be it a betrayal or a trauma
or whatever the more altered you feel
inside of you the more you pay attention
to the cause outside of you so the brain
takes a snapshot it freezes an image and
embosses that pattern neurologically in
the brain that's called a memory so we
create long-term memories from strong
emotional events okay so is that true
that I just want to understand the maybe
the larger the event in terms of its
emotion to the stronger of a hold it has
over you yeah well the more it's
embossed in your biology so some certain
people have a strong experience in their
life and it catches all of the brain's
attention so now they think
neurologically within the circuits of
the past experience and they feel
chemically within the boundaries of
those emotions and so how you think and
how you feel creates a state of being
now here's the problem that if you don't
know how to mediate or control your
emotional reaction to that event and you
keep that refractory period of chemicals
going on with extended periods of time
so that the event produces a chemical
change and the body needs to return back
to homeostasis or balance but if it
can't then the elongation of that
emotional reaction
for weeks say for days or weeks is
called the moon so you say Ed what's
wrong with you I'm in a mood why are you
in a mood well this thing happened to me
five days ago and I'm having one long
emotional reaction so then what you do
is you keep telling the story about it
keep firing and wiring the same circuits
and you keep conditioning the body into
the past so then you wake up in the
morning you look for the emotion
so then now all of a sudden you keep it
lingering for for for weeks or months
that's called the temperament well why
is he so angry I don't know let's ask
him why are you so angry well this thing
happened to me eight months ago I'm
having one long emotional reaction I'm
memorizing my emotions you keep it going
on for years on end that's called a
personality trait so then a person then
is memorizing themselves by living in
the past and so then you say to them
well tell me the story now the latest
research on memory says that 50 percent
of what we talk about in our past isn't
even the truth so we make stuff up about
the past in other words people are
reliving a life that they didn't even
have just to reaffirm that they can't
change right wow so then what's the
significance of this where you place
your attention is where you place your
energy period yes so then the stronger
the emotion that you have the some
problem or condition or person in your
life the more you're paying attention to
them so they captured your attention so
you're giving your power hour away wow
to that person right because they're
capturing your attention so then there's
an energetic connection to every person
everything everything in your past
present reality has your energy
connected to it so now this is the
significance when a person really
decides to be defined by a vision of the
future instead of the memory of the past
the hardest part about it is all of a
sudden becoming conscious and not making
the same unconscious choice so then
if you lower the volume to your
frustration to your hatred to your anger
if you truly knew how to do that if you
lower the volume to that emotion you
would take your attention off that
person which means you would begin to
break those energetic bonds and now
you're taking your power back Crossing
that River of change from the old self
to the new self there's a neurological
biological chemical hormonal a genetic
death of the old self but if you teach
people there's something on the other
side they won't give up on themselves
they'll keep going so there's enough
evidence to encourage people and you
can't tell me you're too old to do this
work you can't tell me you're too sick
to do this work you can't tell me you
had a turbulent past or or that you're
too overweight or too underweight or too
out of shape or you can't even tell me
that you've never meditated before in
fact some of our greatest
scans or people who just have never
meditated before that are not trying to
do anything they just follow
instructions so
our community now is beginning to
understand that it is possible and they
go all in not 50 in not 60 and if we do
a week-long event we got a thousand
people or 1500 people and they are all
in and that when they start getting
Beyond themselves that first day or
second day once they start getting
Beyond themselves and that magic starts
to happen then I have no idea I can't
predict what's going to happen next and
it's usually pretty pretty exciting most
people are waiting for their life the
change yes so they can feel gratitude to
feel abundance to feel whole you know
that's the old model of cause and effect
you know so if you're living with
emptiness you're living with lack you're
living with pain most people have been
conditioned that something out there has
to take away this emptiness or feeling
inside of them but if you believe that
you're creating your life and you're
living by lack well lack isn't going to
create abundance right so
so then it makes sense then that you
don't really actually create wealth you
generate wealth you generate abundance
so the moment you start teaching your
body emotionally what that future is
going to feel like before it's made
manifest well your body is the
unconscious mind believes it's living in
that future in the present moment now
it's the scientific fact that it's the
environment that signals the gene okay
the end product from an experience in
the environment is an emotion so when
you begin to embrace an elevated emotion
you're beginning to Signal the gene
ahead of the environment what's the
importance of that well genes make
proteins and proteins are responsible
for the structure and the function of
your body and the expression of proteins
is the expression of life so by you
creating an elevated emotion and
teaching your body what that future will
feel like before it's made manifest your
body's starting to live in that future
reality in the present moment now here's
the key wow
if you were able to become familiar with
gratitude become familiar with wholeness
become familiar with abundance to become
familiar with freedom and you're able to
generate those chemicals every single
day
more than likely you would be walking
around feeling like your future has
already happened then you would no
longer be looking for it to happen you
would already feel like it has happened
now what is the importance of that well
you're literally becoming somebody else
so you're leaving your lack you're
leaving your guilt you're leaving your
emptiness behind your personality
literally at is made up of how you think
how you act and how you feel
and how you think how you act and how
you feel is your personality and your
personality is intimately connected to
your personal reality your life so then
if you want to change your life your
personal reality you got to change your
personality and here we go again you got
to start becoming conscious of your
unconscious thoughts you got to start
noticing how you act how you speak you
got to pay attention to how you're
feeling some people would live in guilt
their whole entire life and don't even
know it's guilt because at least it
feels like them so then when you start
doing that you begin to objectify your
subjective self so so then
when you begin to make small changes
back to thought a new thought should
lead to a new Choice a new Choice should
lead to a new Behavior a new Behavior
should create a new experience and a new
experience should create a new emotion
yes and that new emotion is teaching
your body chemically to understand what
your mind is intellectually understood
now your body is embodying the truth
right and if you're sitting in a
meditation and your body's thrown the
kitchen sink at you and saying Ed you're
a loser you're never going to change
this is too hard why don't you quit and
you're aware that that's your body doing
that and you say to your body
we're gonna sit here and we're gonna sit
in this fire and I'm going to keep
applying the formula and my your brain
starts running to all the emails you
have to do and you become aware of that
and return back to the present moment
and you tell the body it's no longer the
mind that you're the mind now your will
is getting greater than that program and
there's a liberation of energy and every
time you do that that's a victory and
you teach every time you do that that's
a victory when your mind tells the body
I'm in charge when you say to your when
you you just want to get up and you want
to quit and you go oh no that's my body
bring it back okay and now you're now
you're taming the animal the body is the
animal and you're like a dog you sit and
if you keep doing this keep doing this
you're climbing on top and the body
finally acquiesces it finally says I'm
not going anywhere and then boom there's
this liberation of energy what's the
side effect Joy a person's heart just
automatically opens up and and every
time they do that those victories add up
there's no such thing as a bad
meditation there's only overcoming
yourself and when you sit in the fire
and you work with that people say to me
why do you meditate every morning I say
because if I can overcome myself in the
morning the rest of my day is easy it's
easy because because that's what it's
about you master yourself you master
your life yes and so then all the
chatter in your head that you listen to
all day long that is called the default
mode Network in the brain our research
shows
that shuts off not just shuts off during
the meditation it stays shut off for the
rest of the day so the critic in your
head that's telling you this will never
happen you have enough time all right
that there's no voice there so you just
have a clear flow on where you're going
and you trust yourself more I think that
emotions are energy in motion and so
let's just say that um
we share the same experiences okay and
we're friends and we share the same
experience you're from London I've been
to London my daughter lives in London
and we have hey you do this I do that
you did that you know you own this I own
that you know so what we do is we
actually look to see when we meet people
if we're matching neurologically if
we're matching emotionally so if we
share the same experiences we share the
same emotions and if we share the same
emotions we can relate to one another so
this is where it gets sticky so then the
moment you start saying ah that person
did that to you once yeah that person I
had a similar experience that person did
that to me now now we open the door like
I'm gonna use you to reaffirm
my attachment to that emotion and let's
just work it up so that you can suffer
and I can suffer and then we can have a
conversation and literally we're sharing
the same energy and if we're sharing the
same energy we're sharing the same
information and we're Bound By An
Invisible field
of energy that keeps us connected yes so
then what does it take to break that
energetic field an energy that's greater
than the energy that's holding it
together that's how you separate atoms
that become a molecule you they're
they're Bound By An Invisible field of
energy that's keeping them connected so
you got to use a greater energy than the
energy that's holding them together to
separate them well in order for you to
change then you can't have energy
without awareness or Consciousness
you've got to go to a greater level of
Consciousness and change your energy and
nobody changes Jay until they change
their energy when they change their
energy they change their life so then
you may say well this person you know I
I use this person and I use my enemy to
reaffirm my addiction to hatred I use my
co-worker to reaffirm my addiction to
judgment I use my ex to reaffirm my uh
addiction to resentment that we have
these different people in our lives that
we need to remind us of who we think we
are the enemy dies and you find another
one you know you know your co-worker uh
leaves and you start judging another one
it's just it's not any it's not that so
then
when there's no longer a vibrational
match
when you start doing the work there's no
longer a vibrational match with you and
your past present reality that that
person or that condition any longer
that person or condition is going to
spiral away because you're no longer
you're no longer in need of that so then
our life begins to change when we change
our energy and we begin to take our
power back That's essential for us to
begin to create with now some people
can't handle that because
they're not conscious that they're doing
it so they'll be working on their vision
of their future and yet they'll spend
two hours lowering their energy back
into victimization or suffering and they
want to know why their future isn't
happening well there's an unconscious
program let's go after that and once you
start going after that now all of a
sudden your life starts to change again
so you can't say it doesn't work on some
level we don't work and if you're really
invested in this
the question is what is it about me
where am I directing my attention or my
energy who am I using to reaffirm some
conditioning that I need to remember who
as my old self so then when you stop
reacting to the person or the person's
now complaining to you and you're not
complaining back
it's going to be an uncomfortable moment
because you're all of a sudden seeing a
part of you you used to be that you no
longer are and you have to be willing to
not go there and over time that person
will thank you and they'll say I didn't
even know that I was complaining that
much and by changing yourself you help
others you know it just that's how it
works self-love is no longer about
pleasure or having a car it's something
that you're cultivating within you so
then imagine we have research to show
and this is such a this is such a
duality
that when you start seeing the brain
start synchronizing getting coherent
from the front of the brain and the back
of the brain that two hemispheres coming
together and you we can say to
scientists that come and study our work
oh watch this Ed's gonna pop what do you
mean just watch this is going to be good
and all of a sudden you see this brain
going into this kind of psychic Union
the heart blows wide open you see
coherence going on and you know look
around at that person and there's tears
running down their face
imagine feeling so whole
that it's impossible to want I mean how
can you want when you're whole because
you feel like you already have it now
when you reach that point
that's when the magic happens because
now you are worthy to receive and the
universe only gives us what we think
we're worthy of receiving share this
with them please yeah I think you know
for me I mean
um
I'm curious and I'm a pragmatist I mean
if you tell me something all I want to
know is how I'm going to use it in my
life yes and I'm not into dinner
conversation because nobody changes from
that you know I mean I'm a doer and I
want to be around doers and and this is
why you and I connect so well I think
and I yeah obviously and and and and uh
you you create a group of people
that are passionate about transformation
and they've they've done some of the
work when we were doing our four day
four and a half day advanced workshops
right around the end of the event I was
seeing people starting to know seeing
some really great Transformations and I
thought this is the pop yeah it's a pop
yeah big pops yeah and we were like we
had to send them home and I was like oh
God man if I could just have them for a
week so we created these week-long
events where people Retreat from their
lives and they removed the constant
stimulation in their external
environment that reminds them of who
they think they are as a personality yes
they separate themselves from the people
they know and the places they go and the
things that they do at a certain amount
of time in their routine mundane life so
we'll Bridge a little quantum physics
with a little Neuroscience little neuro
Endocrinology a little epigenetics
psychonur Immunology those are all
Sciences about possibility and I now
know that if you can give people the
sound scientific information and you
know
for me that's the language I know and
then if they can turn to the person next
to them and explain it you're not going
to get off the hook if you can't explain
it it's not wired in your brain but if
you can build a model and explain it
you're installing the neurological
Hardware in your brain in preparation
for the experience so the more you
understand what you're doing and why how
it gets easier because you can assign
meaning to it so then if I can set up
the conditions in the environment and
give them the proper instructions and
push the envelope a little bit Yeah and
people who get their behaviors to match
their intentions and their actions equal
to their thoughts they get their mind
and body working together they're gonna
have a new experience and the experience
then is not only going to enrich the
philosophical circuits in the brain
because experience does that but it's
going to produce an emotion so they're
going to start feeling more unlimited I
believe in human possibility human
potential and I think that one of our
biggest limiting beliefs is the belief
have how limited we really are
and so my interest is to give people
the science to begin to understand how
powerful they really are and I think
that science really is the language that
does that really well and and the new
Sciences like quantum physics and
neuroplasticity Neuroscience
neuroendocrinology you know
psychoneuroimmunology the Mind Body
Connection epigenetics all of those
Sciences point the finger at
possibilities so I want to create a
language for people
from a philosophical or theoretical
standpoint for them to begin to
understand what's possible but then I
want to be able to have those people
begin to wire that information in their
brain completely because learning is
making new connections right in the
brain but remembering is maintaining and
sustaining those connections and it's so
much easier
to lose our vision than to remember it
right so then we have to begin to
hardwire the brain or install the
neurological Hardware in preparation for
an experience so the more people
understand what they're doing and why
then the how gets easier so I want to
then set up the conditions in an
environment in a in a in a workshop
where people can begin to
apply or personalize what they learn so
that they can have an experience and
experience then further enriches the
brain but the prize of an experience is
an emotion and once you start feeling
unlimited once you start feeling
abundant once you start feeling worthy
now you're teaching your body chemically
to understand what your mind is
intellectually understood so knowledge
is for the mind and experiences for the
body and people begin to embody the
truth of that philosophy now if they can
repeat it over and over again it'll
become innate in them it'll become
natural second nature become easier to
begin to master that philosophy so I
want people to begin to understand that
thoughts are very powerful feelings
Drive our thoughts and that they can
begin to create a better life for
themselves once they understand some of
these principles you have to really
begin to
mentally rehearse like so you ask
yourself at the end of your day I do
this every day how'd I do how'd I do
today bro how'd you do did you do good
where'd you fall from grace what what
what was it
that caused you to go unconscious
for the rest of the day like what was
that moment now if you're a student of
Life you'll begin to contemplate well it
was that person that said that thing
then I reacted or this I got this email
or things didn't go my way and I started
feeling angry or frustrated or fearful
the next time that happens
how could I involve my experience now
you may have to search for some answers
of the best model to build or you may
actually have a long contemplation and
start to go God the next time that
happens I think I'm going to do this or
I'm going to do that or I'm going to
plan my behaviors
and the act of closing your eyes
and rehearsing what you're going to do
begins to install the neurological
Hardware in your brain to looks like you
already did it now the brain is no
longer a record of the past now it's a
map to the Future and if you keep
installing that Hardware the hardware
will become a software program which
means you'll just start acting like a
happy person why there's no magic there
you install the circuitry so
that's more important than the news
right it's more important than answering
any email or any text it's more
important than talking about your past
or some dinner
if you can begin to just
think about how you're going to do it
differently that's the building process
neurologically already so now you have
to get conscious in order to do that and
it takes some time it means you got to
shut your cell phone off you got to
close your door you got to take a break
from everything out there and begin to
practice and so by experience then
you start noticing oh here it comes here
comes the frustration here comes the
fear
and now we've given people the tools to
be able to self-regulate to create brain
and heart coherence and so you see
people say excuse me one minute I just
gonna need a minute
it takes some breaths they get back in
they connect to the energy of their
future this is incidental compared to
where they're going so they don't fall
from grace they don't allow their energy
to drop and so yeah in the beginning it
takes a lot because it takes a lot of
energy and awareness to stay conscious
and not go unconscious but if you're
persistent and you're determined then
you're sincere
you begin to figure it out you begin to
say I am not going to give my power away
to that person or that circumstance when
I can use it to heal or to create a new
future and so people then won't excuse
themselves and say I had a hard day
yesterday at a fight with my co-worker
or my ex or and I don't feel like doing
the work well that's the time they get
back on the horse yeah because because
it's the it's all of those times that we
self-correct those are the most valuable
moments thus people who've had
profoundly transcendental experiences
where they we say got lit up they
connected and their brain goes into very
very high coherent States and super
gamma patterns that are way outside of
normal and they have a transcendental
downloader connection that's mystical
they look back at their entire life
they don't want to change one thing in
their past because it got them to that
moment that's the moment the past no
longer exists now by the same means they
look back at their past and they see all
those tough moments where they overcame
themselves and they fall in love with
that person they don't look at the good
meditations or the things that went well
they look they know that it was those
moments that got them to this moment and
I I think then that's when they begin to
understand that that all of the hard
work
all the effort in who we become makes no
one can take that away from us so then
once we arrive at that level and we
experience whatever the dream is or
whatever we create the next thing is do
it until you fully enjoy it and then
when it gets boring or predictable let's
go again let's do something else if we
teach a person then how to trade that
frustration or that hatred for an
elevated emotion and they'll say yeah
but you know it was my ex's fault or I
got betrayed by my partner in business
yeah yeah we know that okay so let's
take your partner in business or take
your ex let's duct tape them put them in
a cannon and shoot them to the moon now
what are you gonna do sooner or later
you got to reckon with yourself and
change right so then teach a person then
how to trade that emotion for an
elevated emotion now trade the emotion
for an elevated emotion right so you're
going to give that up and you're going
to practice feeling gratitude for as an
example yes the person says well I can't
feel gratitude and I say absolutely you
can because you don't practice feeling
it you practice spending most of your
time feeling hatred and frustration so
now it's going to take a little time to
cause that heart of you to bloom or your
part of yours to bloom once they're able
to feel even the smallest measure of
gratitude where they start feeling
appreciation thankfulness
gratitude its emotional signature when
you when you get something when you're
receiving something
when something has happened to you
uh or when something is happening to you
you say thank you because you're
receiving something so the emotional
signature
of gratitude means the event has already
happened or it's happening to you so the
moment you open your heart and you feel
gratitude well that emotion then is
telling the body that the experience has
already occurred and the thought then
can make it into the body because it's
consistent with the thought so now
you're beginning to program the
autonomic nervous system into a very
specific Destiny you got to maintain
that modified State of Mind and Body
your entire day independent of the
conditions in your outer environment
independent of your body's Cravings of
those emotions and habituations and
independent from time and if you can get
ready because something weird or unusual
some synchronicity some coincidence some
opportunity is going to land in your lap
and you didn't have to go and get it yes
it came to you now you're the vortex of
creation so if you say to me well I was
feeling gratitude but then there was
traffic or my co-worker sent me a nasty
email that I would say oh my God God you
mean you're allowing your environment
your outer environment to control how
you feel and think you're back to the
unconscious program that you're the
victim to your life you got it but when
you start producing those outcomes in
your life you're going to pay attention
to what you did inside of you and you're
going to believe more that you're the
creator of your life unless of the
victim of your life the majority of our
thoughts and feelings are connected to
our sexuality
to our victimization our guilt our
suffering or shame or unworthiness or
self-doubt or our importance our control
our fear our anger our frustration our
hatred our judgment those are those are
the first three hormonal centers in the
body and and those first three centers
have everything to do with survival and
those centers are energy consumers
orgasm digestion stress is a lot of
energy that that we're drawing from our
very vital life force yes our resource
of light and information and we're
turning it into chemistry and we're
literally robbing the body's energy
right so so then living like that for
the short term is okay because the body
can move back to homeostasis and then
restore itself but
when we're overdoing that consistently
then there's no energy for growth and
repair there's because you're living
constantly in survival so again you can
eat all the right food you can do all
the right things but if you're living in
anxiety and fear and you're viewing your
world from the worst case scenario that
could possibly happen because that's
what you do in survival there's no
energy for growth and repair there's no
energy for healing so the majority of
our thoughts are signaling certain
circuits in the brain that signal
another part of the brain limit brain to
make what's called a neuropeptide
neuropeptides are chemical Messengers
that signal hormonal centers so now
you're taking thought and you're storing
it as energy in these energy centers and
and if you're living in survival why
would you open your heart I mean it's
just not a time to open your heart I
mean if you're getting chased by T-Rex
it's not a time to meditate it's not a
time to learn it's not a time to connect
it's not a time to communicate it's not
a time to sit down and go within it's
not a time to be vulnerable it's time to
run fighter hide and so is that why
we're this way I've never asked you this
before is this some I don't I don't
think you believe this but I just want
to understand is this some sort of
genetic disposition that's been passed
down to us since we've been chased by
T-Rex I think so I think survival has
been very adaptive yeah like because if
you're being chased by T-Rex you don't
run up to T-Rex T-Rex and say oh cute
little dinosaur let me pet you that's
not adaptive the fear is adaptive you
run from the unknown you run from
challenges right yes so if you're living
in survival there's better chances of
surviving if you run from the unknown
and by the way when you're living in
survival add the infinite Potentials in
the quantum field you'll select the
worst case scenario in your mind and
you'll begin to emotionally prepare
yourself for the worst case scenario
because you have better chances of
surviving there you go if you prepare
for the worst right so people spend
their whole life yes thinking about the
worst thing and emotionally embracing it
while you take a thought and emotion or
an image and an emotion you're your
branding or conditioning your body into
what anxiety into fear so then you keep
doing that over and over again over and
over again your the body becomes the
mind of fear and whether you think you
can control it or not you're going to
have a panic attack and the panic attack
is the body saying you've conditioned me
this way try as you may with your
conscious mind and control it right you
programmed it subconsciously then you
start worrying about the next panic
attack and it's that very anticipation
it keeps the person on the hamster wheel
right robs them of all of this energy as
well they're absolutely so so they don't
believe
impossibility when they're living in
that state because in survival it's not
a time to create all the blood flows
going to the hindbrain and away from the
forebrain there's no there's there's no
physiology really for a person to begin
to create a new future so then so think
about it so then 70 of the time people
in the world are living anticipating the
next moment based on their past moment
and so they're laying reality down
Moment by moment with the next known the
next predictable moment and so the
hormones of stress endorse the senses
our senses become heightened when we're
under stress and we become materialists
we narrow our focus on the danger yes so
then you're focusing on matter you're
focusing on the material world and when
you do that you put all your attention
the arousal of the stress hormones puts
all your attention on your body if
you're being chased by T-Rex you better
be paying attention to your body if the
person's doing the vision board and
they're saying when I get my new car I
get my new house I get my new
relationship then I'm gonna feel so
great now that well then they're back to
the program waiting for it to happen for
them to feel the emotion they're
believing their outer world has to
change in order for them to feel better
there's there's no effect of drawing the
experience to you with that way
so the person has to use those tools
to get them into the emotional state
for them to feel like it's already
happened now think about this if you get
up from
a creative process and you feel grateful
you feel A Love For Life you feel a joy
for existence you feel a passion that to
for the moment
uh you you will not be looking for your
future because you'll feel like it's
already happened it's the moment that we
start feeling those self-limiting
emotions that we feel separation and
then we start looking for it again well
then if you're waiting you're not
creating your you're in separation again
so then yeah so then
whatever it takes for you to move into a
state of being and what is a state of
being thoughts are the vocabulary of the
brain feelings are the vocabulary of
your body how you think and how you feel
creates your state of being so then if
you wake up in the morning and you come
come back to your senses with a clean
slate and you say I don't feel anything
you say well let me start thinking about
all the problems in my life well all
those problems are connected to
different people or different objects of
things at different times and places the
moment you remember your problems a
memory is a record of the past you're
thinking in the past every one of those
problems has an emotion associated with
them so all of a sudden you start
feeling unhappy you start feeling bitter
you start feeling frustrated so now your
body's in the past so then most people
then
create a state of being that's connected
to their past and if they're in the
familiar past
then they are going to Crave the
predictable future and they're going to
fall back into routine so then we want
people then to get very clear on that
vision of their future however they do
it and begin to combine that clear
intention with an elevated emotion and
the stronger the emotion they feel from
the vision they're creating the more
altered they feel inside of them the
more they're going to pay attention to
the pictures in their mind and now
they're remembering their future and
biologically it's exactly the same as
remembering your past in fact if you're
not being defined by a vision in the
future it means you're making your past
more real than your future you're
falling in love with your past you're
more in love with your past than you are
with your future that you're believing
in your past more than you're believing
in your future when you get to that
moment where you have that feeling
that's your compass because that feeling
is going to drive your behaviors it's
going to drive more of those thoughts
and when you feel that feeling and it's
visceral
no person no thing no experience will
stand in the way between you and that
vision and and you will be initiated in
by the universe into wealth you will be
initiated into Health you'll be
initiated into Freedom those people all
those people that have healed themselves
of all those different health conditions
they are so humble and so happy and they
feel so great that they would never
trade this feeling because of what you
thought of them they they've they've
left that program behind a long time ago
they actually don't care how you think
of them they they actually are so happy
with themselves that they're no longer
dependent on anything outside of them
now I think that's a really important
moment because that's the moment we give
people permission in our lives to do the
same right and I think that more and
more people are beginning to figure that
out if you want another Amazing Joe
dispenza clip check it out right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there